welcome everyone we are ready to start
and we're gonna talk about the past
pounds and what can you do when you have
a passed pawn in this game it's a very
recent game actually played in a world
of the rapid championship end of
December and I had to pass pawns and I
managed to use them you know to get a
win so it's a lot of times you have a
pause fun you have to know what to do
with it you know how to push it push one
all the way push them together
simultaneously so it's tricky so let's
go over this game my opponent is a
strong Grandmaster from Vietnam quién
and drone songs are very good players
they play d4 d5 c4 and he took and
immediately we have the opening that is
called anybody Queens gambit accepted
because he took upon he accepted it so
we have a Queens gambit accepted so we
play III the idea to put pressure on c4
now if black plays b5 it's a really bad
move here do you know how to take
advantage of it or what to do
a4 perfect
if pawn goes on a6 you just take take
pick up the rock okay you just take this
guy winning the rook and if he plays c6
take E Queen f3
and winning the rock or a piece okay so
he played Knight f6 Bishop takes c4
III this is normal
Knight f3 and now c5 I castle 86 so this
is the main line here White has so many
different ideas here you can play a four
you can play Queen e2 you can play
Bishop b3 you can play Knight c3 so
countless countless the possibilities
here so you can choose I chose this book
have you seen this idea before this is a
more quiet approach going for an endgame
with a small plus because you have a
little bit better development and try to
squeeze a win so this is a 15 minute
game so this is the world the rapid
championship so I don't know you
probably heard of this tournament this
was in Saudi Arabia last December so a
huge tournament all the best players
were there basically and you know I
fought against best of the best in this
tournament first round I was purely
against vision and then I play Sega
Kuryakin in a blitz portion I played
Magnus Carlsen I mean lots of lots of
very top top players so it was a really
exciting tournament I did quite well in
the rapid which is this one it's quite
well here finishing with the +3 score
you know it was really good finished in
that in that portion so he took he takes
because if he doesn't take I will take
his queen and then he will lose his turn
to castle he takes
okay now you play 92 the knight on c3
it's not very effective here so you play
Knight d2 because you want to be able to
play Bishop e2 and then some nice e4
ideas you know a bishop will gum here 94
some kind of ideas like this 90 d7
Bishop e2 b6
94 threatening 96 Bishop d7 and now if I
play 96
it's just I'm losing too much time you
know I'm losing too much time and my
bishop is not coming out so this is not
this is not particularly that great for
me because I can't really develop this
if I move the bishop he just takes if I
play betrayed runs into 93 sorry
even though optically it looks good but
I can't really do anything so so that
would be too much and by the way do you
know why he played b6 here and not to
move b5 because it looks b5 is better
right because it's control c4 yeah white
it's a 4 and then puts pressure on b5 if
capture rook takes put it pressure on
these things okay
94 they should be 7 b3
castles there should be to just develop
my pieces then I want to play at OKC one
just get the development I feel slightly
very slightly better for why because of
some little weaknesses d6 squared to
work with rock ft 8 look a c1 why it has
that extra tempo that initially you
started with so just every move I'm just
trying to pose some little problems for
him so it's not easy to just equalize
the game here so he played the move 9f8
so he's trying to change exchange pair
of the rocks now what can you do
hey if you exchange one pair of rooks
it's gonna be little bit easier for him
so let's drink here and for a moment and
try to find what is the best move here
for white bishop d4 Bravo cloud you
excellent thinking yes that bishop is an
important piece tell us why you think or
why am I saying it's important piece
okay
b6 d6 right so if that bishop if this
bishop is gone suddenly this is a little
weak
this is little weak little problems and
you know move like b5 he doesn't solve
the problem you can go 95 you know he
doesn't necessarily solve the problem
okay so he goes back by myself that's
what we did a concession and he went
back and then he came back so again my
Knights are looking more active my rook
star in the game and his rook is still
in the corner so it's time to press now
how are we gonna press now to get
something out of this I want you to
press him of course 96 ah sorry Bishop
f3 first trade the bishops because that
Bishop is good important piece take 96
is coming the reason I didn't go 96
because I didn't see what do I do after
let's say Bishop d5 and then he goes 95
then I have to go back if you don't have
a follow-up here
take I take with this because I want to
have a lift and plus I want to keep my
knight on d4 so he goes okay c8 now 96
exchanging the pair of rooks and now my
nights are very active 96 is threatened
as well okay so 96 is threatened now
he goes 95 activating his knife and
putting pressure putting pressure on my
night so now what can you do
94 to take it right yeah b5 we just can
go 9 85 so he goes 96 he's holding it
seems like he's just holding this
perfect Knight b6 excellent Knight b6
yes now he has to take it well I mean if
he takes here I mean that just down upon
and he's gonna probably lose so he goes
Knight B 393 it's not good by the way
because of rook c8 takes that's good
okay extra pawn so he counter sacrifice
counter sacrifice on B three counter
sacrifice on B three now
I took with the night I could also take
back with the pawn but he takes back
Knight b6 not so clear so I took back
with the night he takes now
Roxy six putting pressure on the night
and putting pressure on the palm
rook b8
ninety-five activating the night now
right now I have a more active night
look and more active night so I just
repeat it one time here if you move the
way I take the night so it has to go
here I can force a draw here but I'm not
interested I pay for but it's good to
repeat because you get additional time
it's an increment so you get a little
bit of time and now you played a 4h six
he gets his lift now I played f4 okay I
repeat it one more time four again it's
not easy for him to just to equalize
this so he placed ninety five back he's
trying to activate his rook he went for
a logical idea just to try to get active
perhaps he should have just sit and play
a move like g5 that would have been
embarrassed now he's gonna lose upon an
important pawn how okay six nine goes g5
take take okay five it's outside passed
pawn it's a good pun okay to have but
now he is getting active Rock PQ do you
guys see the threat now he's setting up
a threat absolutely the threat is Knight
takes III tricky what to do
King f3 then some g-force you know I
think you want to go to f3 you know how
about g3 so they don't you don't you
don't get you with the tempest okay
King g7 quite a hard position to win I
can tell you it's a very technical
position to win it's not easy at all now
you need to have a good idea to simplify
the position a little bit because this
Knights on the board is a little bit of
a problem because Knights are you know
they can tricky they can jump always and
create threats I rather go to a rook
endgame here so let's think of a way
that we can do that a creative way okay
a creative way to get some kind of a
routine game with gusto where we still
have the extra pawn any ideas you can
see
I realize if I can get the nights off
and at the right sequence maybe I'll
have some good chances to win this night
is not a very strong piece when you have
a past Pony trying to push because it's
not very stable like the bishop is much
better in this kind of situations this
is a pretty creative idea
Knight e4 maybe what do you think you
attacking the pawn if you please have
six that will weaken the position quite
a lot
you have Roque six ideas and putting
pressures here's to go here and now who
can see the tactical idea that will
allow you to get into a rook endgame
good potential with good potential to
win yes perfect
he takes e4 look at that now we get rid
of that Knight
and now we come to the main idea well
actually I didn't get before we take
what do we do
insert the check right and now we take
now we come to the main and point it
here so we have this position where I
have two outside passed pawns one on a
one on age how to win this this is
actually a winning endgame he he should
have kept his King on f6 that would have
given better chances and but this next
one is very important to find how should
I try to win this if I'm not sure
because maybe maybe it'll be five works
too but I'm not sure if that's the best
look a six
haha what about the move okay eight with
idea to push the pawn all the way to 87
and then threaten Luke h8 so he goes
here f3 now if he takes you see check
and we take the rock so he goes back
push push push
normally you don't do that if I didn't
have this postpone I couldn't do that
okay
but I can now because I have this H pawn
now he goes here now you're probably
wondering why not here right if he does
this I can go even keenya for push I go
here and then I will put them into a
sucker bunk okay you will see that's
gonna happen in the game so I push you
in here and now it's very very tricky
moment here I need to force I need to
get my king to cross the fourth-ranked
okay but what's the best way to do that
I can't go here he is keeping me cut
what's the best way to do it
now his King cannot move by the way he
couldn't capture because of the rock AJ
check and promotion of the pawn so now
we see that I advance my past pass to
the maximum and the final step is to
find a way to win this can you have to
correct
he cuts
he pushes yeah if he plays d3 we always
have King g3 so he checks the problem is
he can't if he cannot take because I
just moved the rook and he cannot stay
here
so like he goes here I go here you go
here I go here and now he's a super Munk
King cannot move pawn moves I take and
rook moves away okay if you station a
file I take on d3 now he goes here kingi
for f4
now he isn't socks oven again so he goes
here take and now how are you gonna
cross this again it's the key that I
have my f-pawn here if I don't have the
f-pawn this is a draw if we take this F
and H F pounds it's even two extra parts
of the draw king c3 before now
not King before knocking before because
he's gonna do the cut then you have to
take things before so I go here and now
he resigned here but here I just go here
he can't take block h8 mate so if he
moves on a side rook b8 if he goes okay
six then I win this this is already easy
the way you would win this you would
just go here you would go away from the
checks and just use the spawn as a decoy
now it's three pounds this is a win even
without this point now it's a win
because you can never take through
covers it stays you push you can't take
it he has a couple of checks but you can
just come up to him and you continue
push got it so yeah so this is the idea
in a routine game how to use your past
pawns
see as soon as we reach this position I
knew one thing I need to normally you
want to put the rook on a side of course
on you want to put the rook on the side
or behind the past pawn but in this
particular case I recognize that I
probably can win this even if I put the
rook on it and push it all the way to
Asia because that will limit his options
again key factor is that I have this
pawn if I have the H pawn I cannot do
that from here it's a draw
yeah without F pumps it's a draw without
the H pawn and the D pawn as a draw so
again so I want to put attention to this
crucial moment is here I think this
moment I played really precisely Knight
e4 the knight is strong on d5 so I'm
trying to get
it'll take 94 and here important to
check here you should have kept the king
on f6 see he went to age five and then
he went back again to g7 that was quite
a quite a lot of time he wasted there
okay but he was trying to win the age
fund that was his idea but King f6
offers him the best joining chances take
and now let's take it through now take
it through now the game to get the win
go ahead what did I play now is
threating a rook d 4g for chat
well the rookie for check it gets little
tricky
I want to stop rook G for check do you
see a move to do that
yep
and now the trick is how to cross yeah I
want to win the deep under I don't want
to start crossing with a king when the
deep on is there so I would like to get
it deep on first so that way I know I
can win this no problem
and we get to it okay very very
important to remember this idea okay
that you can push your pants all the way
when you have two of them it's very very
difficult for him to do anything okay
okay now we're gonna do I want to do a
couple of studies and and that's going
to involve our same team today of past
pants okay
one of the general rule is past pounds
meant to be pushed so remember always
try to push them when you have a chance
okay now what can you do right to play
and win when you're trying to solve this
kind of positions look for a little bit
unusual ideas - not just the most
natural moves okay sometimes you have to
waste the tempo to get to the right
position okay okay
King f3 by Claudio so let's say I play
okay I will try c6
okay don't fashion so I go see five
now he's threatening the e6 and f7 mate
and if I go here King d6 King the seven
wins right this you will win oops that's
just made
if you push us you just go here and eh
so
what if he goes here he faces the king
not letting you to win easily
well if I just put d3 I mean there is a
danger Kings if I I put d3 you might
even lose there so you have to be
careful
I'm threatening to push so King c4
correct and now King see fire now I want
to take the pawn he pushes he pushes he
pushes checkmate very very nice okay yes
so you have to you have to very
important this of course the king of GID
and here another idea King c4 and here
if you place King here King this seven
okay so again we come back to the
original position so you have a very
strong passed pawn here but not easy to
win it so you have to find a move king
f3 he is waiting you are waiting he goes
here it's same exact thing if he plays
King gauge it's same exact idea you
reach this position okay
now here's Nomos if you push you take
says to go back take and you get there
okay alright next position you might be
familiar with this phone but I'm not
sure so this is a I really like this
this study it's white to play white to
play and make a draw
you want to try to make a drill how f4
but you have to calculate yeah so f4 if
he takes then you're happy right you
just quit yeah this this and your queen
with the check you actually win this so
King c7
now
that's the problem now the king is gonna
stop your palms and the question is if
you're going to be able to stop his
a chick's 1g5 but what is your plan I'm
quitting Claudia still need change III
what do we call this idea what do you
think the idea is if I might have showed
this if you were self still made
everybody self still made you create
still made to your king
and do this this is amazing idea if one
more move Queen here he would go back
down here and say checkmate to you that
wouldn't have been good okay but he
doesn't have that one more would got it
so remember okay yes and if he didn't
have let's say he doesn't play this move
right now what do you do dink-dink don't
rush okay don't rush one wrong move and
you lose it
because if you go for the same idea
right I think you lose because I still
draw
yeah it's still a draw but in fact here
there is a problem there is this move
now you know I take
check
yeah you might even you may very well
win this you know something like this
okay so that's why he has to play the
move king c7 in order to prevent that
okay in order to prevent that ideas
alright next position again we are only
using some ideas today where we had the
team of passed pawns now normally
speaking position like this will always
be a draw okay because the bishop is a
very powerful piece and he usually will
have no problem stopping the a passed
pawn okay he normally wouldn't have a
problem stopping that white to play and
you want to find a way to win this game
a five okay Bishop here
now you're stopping and you're ready to
push right you're going to go a six a
seven to push and win it
so he goes Bishop h6 back because he
wants to come here once he gets here
then that's it you're not going to be
able to do anything
sorry what do you do
g5 check if King takes you just push it
okay
Bishop takes threatening to go here
again now don't rush you must play
precisely here you have to take
advantage of the bad placement of the
night okay sorry the placement of the
King that is blocking the bishop what's
the move King before unfortunately runs
into the problem of this move and Bishop
goes back to b8 then he stops it okay
another trick he has is this and then
lets you queen and get behind it with
the check
so not King before
but again you have to control the III
square perfect yes perfect yes now he
goes here perfect yes you control that
then you get that any questions
and now the apon cannot be stopped again
this King is on a word square possible
here just completely blocking the night
the blocking the bishop then he cannot
go anywhere so again when you have two
pots pawns you can always have some
ideas some tricks you know you can try
to use so try to try to remember this
ideas okay again and again when you have
a passed pawn you push it he goes here
to control it King d5 and in this
position the motif you're using the
motif of g5 it's deflection okay you're
deflecting and blocking the piece here
with a g5 if King takes you just go a
six a seven if Bishop takes King G for
controlling III he goes here Kings f3
controlling f2 and that cannot be
stopped
got it so that's the main ideas for you
to remember a couple of things to
remember the rook endgame that we went
over okay in the studies okay so you
always try to use them and you don't
want to be rushing to push them such
sometimes you have to prepare so in the
rook endgame I put the rook on eight and
start preparing so to learn more
exercises you do and see games that's
how you're gonna get better okay
[Music]